thank you
for joining us and welcome to the press
conference following the vtc
of the eu 27 leaders on covet
coordination i'm glad
you have all tuned in massively please
note that we have a translation in
many languages german french spanish
italian english
and dutch as well we'll take questions
but first
let's go to the president of the
european council
the
alexis navalny about nalix ality navalny
we condemn his detention by the russian
authorities
mr navalny's rights must be fully
and unconditionality we call on russia
to release him immediately and ensure
his safety
we expect russia to urgently proceed
with the independent and transparent
investigation
into the attack on his life and to fully
cooperate with the organization
for the prohibition of chemical weapons
to ensure
an impartial international investigation
of christian dutch
[Music]
[Music]
leaders want vaccination to be
accelerated
and in this respect commitments on
deliveries made by companies
must be respected leaders reaffirmed
that vaccines should be distributed
at the same time and must be on
proactive population basis
and we reaffirmed the need to have a
close follow-up
of the vaccination process all possible
means will be examined
to ensure rapid supply including earth
distribution to avoid delays
we discussed also the question of
vaccine certificates
and we think that we should be able to
agree
on common elements to include in the
certificates for medical purposes
and at a later stage we can see
if and in which circumstances
this certificate can be used suggestions
certificate
thank you mr president madam president
you have the floor
thank you indeed across europe the
health
situation remains very serious
and yes there is reason for hope because
of the vaccines
but there's also strong reason for
concern
with the new variants we are observing
we must
therefore remain focused and we must
remain determined in our response
we must ensure delivery of vaccines from
the companies
and we must ensure the quick and
efficient use of the available
vaccines i am glad that we agreed with
with member states to administer as many
doses as possible over the next weeks
and months
of course to support this we are working
hand-in-hand with
emma and the companies we are determined
to provide to provide
more predictability and stability to the
delivery process
and we look forward to more vaccines
and more doses coming on the stream on
stream
soon at the same time
we are increasingly concerned about
different different
variants of the virus thus we need much
better knowledge
of the real presence and the real spread
of these
variants of the virus and all that
in all the different places in the
european union and that is why
we need more testing and more sequencing
after positive testing throughout the
entire
european union today the situation is as
such
that almost all member states are
sequencing
less than one percent of the positive
tests we have only two member states
that are testing around 10 percent and
that is necessary
so this is far too little and therefore
we need to increase the sequencing to at
least
five percent of all positive tests the
commission
will support this effort thanks to ecdc
capacities in this field and targeted
funding a word to
the border situation indeed in order to
keep our
external and internal borders open
we need targeted measures that keep us
all safe we have an increase in
infections across europe and at the same
time
the just mentioned new variants are
spreading in europe
and to identify such high risk areas
we need we think to refine our mapping
so we propose that a newly introduced
category of
dark red a dark red zone would show
that in this zone the virus is
circulating at a very high level
persons traveling from dark red
areas could be required to do a test
before departure
as well as to undergo quarantine after
arrival this is
within the european union and in view of
the very serious health
situation all non-essential travel
should be strongly discouraged both
within the country and of course across
borders
at the same time it is absolutely
important to keep the single market
functioning so
concerning essential workers and goods
they must continue to cross
borders smoothly this is of utmost
importance
with regard to the external borders we
will also propose to have additional
safety measures
for those traveling from third countries
on essential travel
to europe we would for example require
testing before departure
finally we had some discussions around
the certificates
to be issued to people who have received
the vaccines
i believe we have to differentiate two
different
issues the first one is plain and simply
the
documentation itself a documentation or
vaccination
is a medical necessity and there is a
global standard for this
you all know it it is the waho's
yellow international certification
the second question is what can you use
this certificate for the used to be made
of this certificate must be very
carefully
considered there are few yet unknown
variables to take into account
for example the medical question does
vaccination inhibit transmission
of the virus by the vaccinated person we
have no answer on that
and how long is the vaccination
effective we do not know that for
certain
either and then the political question
how do you ensure that you respect the
rights of
those who have not had access to a
vaccine
and what other alternatives do you offer
to those
who have legitimate reasons for not
getting
the vaccine and at the same time how do
we protect
the personal data of citizen so open
questions here
therefore later on when the time is ripe
we will need a thorough debate and a
consensus among member
states on possible other uses of the
certificate
last but not least we have discussed
europe but we do not forget
the rest of the world the pandemic is
global
in a couple of months in europe we will
have more doses
than we can use with biontech and
moderna
authorized we can vaccinate up to 85
of the eu population these are 380
million people
at the same time other parts of the
world the poorer ones
see themselves as left behind in the in
the axis of covet 19 vaccines
from the start we have invested in covax
the global vaccine procurement facility
covax remains the best route for
universal
vaccine solidarity but as there is a
global rush
to vaccines there is thus a shortage
i have suggested an eu mechanism to
share
access to some of our vaccines
until covax is able to deliver poor
countries
with large quantities of vaccines
vaccines that we agreed to share as part
of
team europe could be channeled through
covax
we can and we should do this without
disrupting ongoing national vaccination
plans
and in coordination with the companies
this is also a question of self-interest
the longer and the more the virus
circulates
in the world the more risk of mutations
and the more risks to our own health we
have
therefore it is very it is also in our
self-interest
to share early enough vaccines with
other regions of the world
thank you madam president we'll take a
few questions now and i'll start with
uh nicos crisolares from bloomberg
nichols
please turn on your camera as yes
can you hear listen to me
yeah mr president you said that
uh uh and madame president you both said
that lockdown measures uh
uh and restrictive measures must
continue
and be strengthened do you have a
a time frame for how long given also the
fact
that as far as i can hear you didn't
commit at least explicitly to the
commission's proposal to vaccinate
70 percent of the population uh by
summer
and my second question you said that all
business and laser travel non-essential
travel should be discouraged
strongly discouraged how this
discouragement will be enforced
yeah first of all there is a global and
clear support for this proposal of the
commission
this is an ambitious rule this ambition
an ambitious goal sorry
of course 70 of our people in europe
vaccinated
by by the by the summer but at the same
time it's very important to accelerate
vaccination
and we discussed a lot what are the
different tools we have
and the european commission clarified
shared with all the leaders
very important information in order to
demonstrate that even
if we face obstacles we are trying to
work very hard
in order to to overcome those obstacles
and you know
in order to to find concrete solutions
is my first point
my second point of course the
vaccination is the the beginning
of something which is more positive and
there is more hope
but at the same time we have understood
especially the last
weeks that we face new variants
especially but not
only the british variants of the travail
traffic 19
it means that we need to remain very
vigilant
that probably we need to confirm to
maintain
or to add sometimes very strong
measures in order to limit the spread of
the virus
and that's why also because we try to
learn the lessons of the past
we have clearly said that we want to
maintain
the functioning of the single market but
at the same time for the not
essential travels we accept that
probably
we need to decide some restrictive
measures
in a european approach based on a
european cooperation a european
coordination
and until when it will be necessary to
to keep
those very uh important and difficult
measures
uh the the the the the the common goal
is to limit the spread of the virus and
we will
assess the situation taking into
consideration the positive effects
of the measures that we we need to take
yes i can only underline
what xiaomi shell just said so the
european europe is more or less one
epidemiological zone
at the moment being with a relatively
high level
of the spread of the virus and
completely disseminated
and as it is absolutely crucial
to keep internally the single market
going
and for example to have a seamless
procedure for cross-border workers
health workers for example who live on
one side
of a former border and work on the other
side of this former border so to keep
the borders in general open for that it
is necessary
that we have a common understanding
and a common agreement how to deal with
the different zones
a light red zone or a dark red zone
and to have targeted measures one of the
most important measure is
just to discourage unnecessary
unessential travel and unless
unnecessary movements in order just to
keep
the essential movements i've just been
describing
open the commission will come with a
proposal how to deal with that
what the internal market is concerned
but also what our external borders are
concerned
uh on monday in the relevant
uh committee this is the ipcr
in order to discuss with the member
states how we can
proceed on that matter in a coordinated
manner
and indeed there was a lot of support
for the goal to
have by summer vaccinated 70 percent of
the adult
population if you look at the delivery
schedules
of the vaccines this is doable
it's an enormous effort i mean this
mass vaccination at a continental scale
we've never done before so we all know
that we have to join forces it it is an
enormous effort but it is doable
and we are determined to reach this goal
thank you next question uh will be for
uh isabel europe is
um
okay um in in general of course it is
member states decision
but we've learned the lesson that it is
good that we coordinate as much as we
can
um to give you an example of course the
borders the the virus
do not know and respect any kind of
former borders
we do not have borders anymore former
borders within the european
union the schengen area so you can have
a an area where there is
on both sides and two member states uh
close to each other
the same epidemiological situation but
if in one half in this zone you do a
strong lockdown and in the other half of
this zone
you keep shops open you will have
immediately movement of people to the
other side
to do shopping for example thus
pushing forward the spread of the virus
and the dissemination of the virus
so it is smart to look at homogeneous
areas and there have targeted measures
that the member states then can in
coordination
apply to make sure that we contain the
spread of the virus as much
as possible and on the other hand
keep the flow in the single market as
much as possible open
thank you next question will be for
thomas thomas gucker
yes thanks a lot um one question
or two questions to the president of the
commission
please germany has specifically called
for a testing required for cross-border
workers
um has there been support for this
idea um especially when it would be
between dark red and
red zones um and um
how are you no and and then and another
question please
for the president of the council you
mentioned the
support for the 70 vaccination goal
has there also been support for the 80
percent
goal so 80 percent of people over 80
years
by march thank you unanimous support
should i that please yeah so
um the the question you were
raising for example is let's take um
a a border um close to or
a country close to luxembourg you know
that healthcare workers
working in luxembourg often live
in one of the neighboring countries and
if that would be a dark red zone
within the zone of course uh any kind of
movement is
um discouraged but cross
border workers would have to go to work
because they are
essential health care workers so this is
not the problem but it would be a
problem
if all of a sudden there would be a
closure of border between
luxembourg and the neighboring country
that would not
make any sense because they are the same
epidemiological
zone if you look at different zones then
of course it is a decision of the member
states
together how to restrict travel whether
it requires testing or other measures
this is a decision that has to be taken
now in the next days we will debate it
there will be a proposal on it
the thought behind it is that we
understand uh once again that we are one
epidemiological zone and not divided in
different member states where we have
different situations
and we will only contain the virus if
we have targeted measures and not
unnecessary measures like
blanket closure of borders which would
severely hurt our economy but not
very much restrict the virus
i have a next question
thank you mr president uh next question
is for tanya tanya malievska
from mia tanya hi
just a sec hi yes it's daniel from the
macedonian news agency i have a question
on the western balkans
uh so you mentioned the sharing
mechanism for vaccines and
kovacs so can you can you give us some
sort of of deadline
of timeline when the western balkans can
ex
can expect some vaccines north macedonia
has been buying now vaccines from serbia
uh or at least receiving from serbia
serbia is buying them so
clearly the european union is for the
moment failing the western balkans so
can you can you
explain when can the citizens in the
western balkans expect some
kind of help in terms of vaccines thank
you
so the answer is as soon as possible we
are going a double track
the one is as you know we have strongly
supported from the very beginning kovacs
the kovacs facility that is built
because
just for the purpose um to provide
vaccines to low and middle income
countries um
europe is at the moment being the
largest uh
gives the largest funds um to the
covax facility but we obviously see that
it is for covax too at the moment being
difficult
to acquire vaccines and therefore we are
establishing now
in a second track also the mechanism in
the european union
to uh to to to
get doses from the member states
that then are being donated as team
europe
for example to our neighborhood in the
western balkan
i will take a last question from
rob herbaugh rope you have the floor
yes good evening um wouldn't it be
simpler to have just an outright ban
on non-essential travel instead of
in dark red zones and talking about
strongly
discouraging non-essential travel
one word about that we we repeat that we
try to learn the lessons
and uh we think it's important to
guarantee uh the french university
in point one on the other hand we know
that it will be probably necessary to
take additional
restrictive measures uh in order to to
limit
the not essential uh travels and it's
the orientation that we are that you are
taking
in in the next hours and it's this we
will
work again in order to coordinate in
order to cooperate
based on common sense uh based on this
idea that it's important to limit the
spread of the various
explains i've explained very clearly i
think the reasons point one
but at the same time at the same time we
think that it's important
to to avoid having or facing disruptions
in the functioning of the new markets
yeah
i i can only underline this so the
decision has to be taken
first of all that we have this common
approach with the different zones
instead of thinking in member states
categories
that is the first important step then to
think about
the mechanisms where we have learned
that they're
helping to limit the spread of the virus
and therefore discouraging strongly
non-essential travel is one of the means
testing requirements for example is
another one
so these these are two options of many
in a basket
that you can choose depending on what
color the zone is you are looking at
this will be developed in detail in the
next
days and again it's last but not least a
member state decision
but as they were asking strongly for
common coordination which is
sensible in this in
the situation we are in with the spread
of the virus
and the the fact that we are looking at
new variants
in the european union it is a very good
step forward
that proactively now we are looking at
this situation together as 27.
thank you madam president and mr
president this concludes our press
conference of tonight
see you soon thank you
[Music]
you